another day and sadly another mass
school shooting in the United States of
America this one at Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School in parkland Florida
17 people were killed mostly kids when
the alleged shooter a 19 year old former
student of the same school entered the
school and started shooting and the
shooter reportedly activated a fire
alarm he was wearing a gas mask he had
smoke bombs that he was tossing he also
had an ar-15 style rifle and lots of
ammunition and after the shooting took
place he at least temporarily avoided
being captured by police by blending in
with students who were running away but
he was eventually tracked down and
arrested and this is an individual who
passed a background check and had
purchased an ar-15 style weapon legally
he had made threats against other
students in the past he was banned from
wearing a backpack on campus and he was
later ultimately expelled for fighting
in an incident that related to some kind
of high school relation relationship
drama of sorts the details of which I
don't exactly remember this is a student
who was part of the Junior ROTC which
had awarded him multiple times for
outstanding academic performance
students after the fact have said that
the student joked about shooting places
up and seemed to have what other
students described as anger issues he
had online profiles with pictures of him
with guns and knives and listen I don't
know even how many details to give you
about the specific shooting and the
shooter right because it's another one
it's another one of these horrible
shootings with as is often the case
legally purchased guns and this incident
now gets a ton of attention but of
course the bigger picture numbers are
absolutely horrifying and most of the
incidents don't get any attention right
we've had over 6500 gun
violence incidents this year so far it's
mid-february and we've had over 6500
incidents we're desensitized to the
numbers over 1,800 gun related deaths in
2018 so far more than three thousand
injured injured by incidents of gun
violence during this year 69 kids under
age 11 have been killed this year I'm
not talking about the last two years or
five years or ten years just in the
first six weeks of 2018 12 to 17 year
olds over 300 killed we've had 30 of
what you would call mass shootings Plus
over 200 of what are sometimes called
accidental or unintentional shootings
others I like to call them negligent
discharges of firearms which should be
treated as such criminally and of course
right when one of these incidents
happens like the one yesterday at
parkland Florida we start hearing it's
not the time to talk about gun control
it's not the time to politicize a
national tragedy it's not about gun
safety regulations or anything else and
of course that makes no sense right we
can't politicize it is code for we
shouldn't talk about how to prevent it
right after the shooting but then when
time passes people just forget and then
that also ends up not being the time to
talk about how to prevent it because
we've forgotten about it and also a
serious conversation about gun control
would probably take place over the
course of a couple of months yes and we
see these mass shootings on average just
about every month so that's an
impossible standard of that they're
creating there's essentially no time
period because of the frequency of these
where it can be a long time since the
last one because they're happening all
the time now the president Donald Trump
took to Twitter reacting initially with
the tweet that many of the involved are
not happy with right his tweet was my
prayers and condolences to the families
of the victims of the terrible Florida
shooting no child teacher or anyone else
should ever feel unsafe in anime
in school and then this morning sending
out another tweet where he said so many
signs that the Florida shooter was
mentally disturbed even expelled from
school for bad and erratic behavior
neighbors and classmates knew he was a
big problem must always report such
instances to authorities again and again
a lot of people who were at the school
families of the victims friends of
people at the school aren't pleased with
what Donald Trump has said so far about
this one student from the school
actually called Donald Trump a piece of
[ __ ] pardon my language over the tweet
of condolence saying I don't want your
condolences you effing piece of s my
friends and teachers were shot multiple
of my fellow classmates are dead do
something instead of sending prayers
prayers won't fix this but gun control
will prevent it from happening again
I've been thinking a lot about this
incident and and sort of the incidents
in their totality that we've had in 2018
in the last two years in the last five
years the last 10 years has anyone else
noticed that we rarely see anger
expressed in the media about these
incidents I mean it sort of makes sense
right the victims and their families are
sad and they're traumatized and they're
distraught and they're despairing but
big picture as a country we should be
furious about this because it keeps
happening and nothing is being done
media covers the crime and the despair
and the people left behind by the
criminality but what about the angry
voices that are saying we should be
furious that it happened again and we
want answers now as to why nothing has
been done and we demand that our elected
officials actually take action because
they don't take action
there's no marches from the countless
numbers of people affected by gun
violence demanding action from our
lawmakers and I'm not criticizing them
for that I'm telling you it's just not
happening
we're not seeing action taken don't we
need some anger here because when it's
only despair and sadness and not anger
we're not catalyzing change
and it's almost like it becomes
ritualized in the United States
Americans kill each other with guns we
see the reports on TV there is calls for
prayers and condolences and now we need
a soul-searching moment but then there's
never any action nothing ever is
actually done yeah I think there are two
ways for people to respond to this one
is to be angry and the other one is to
be desensitized to it yes I know that
three of the biggest mass shootings in
American history three of the 10 have
occurred all in the last few months Las
Vegas the Texas Church shooting that's
right and now this school shooting yep
so it's a problem that's accelerating
are people going to be as angry as the
initial one like Columbine back in 1999
probably not part of it is
desensitization and I that that's a
problem we also have to talk about right
because for many of us it's you turn on
the TV and oh there's been another
shooting 17 killed here's video of SWAT
officers storming classrooms and what's
for dinner tonight and is tonight the
couple's figure-skating or the solo
figure skating on the Olympics right so
the desensitization is definitely a big
big part of it but it's also the fact
that it's always the soul-searching that
doesn't ever go anywhere right because
we actually need to take action and
there's no one thing that will prevent
every incident and that's part of the
problem we get this collective amnesia
right the shooting happens there's
coverage and then the demands not to
politicize there's no change and then we
all sort of forget about the issue until
the next one and it's never mentioned
that hey this has been going on for
years and we never do anything we have a
second Amendment right responsible
ethical gun ownership of reasonable
weapons is is a part of American society
like it or not but if you're not a
police officer or SWAT or military or
whatever you just don't need assault
weapons you don't need weapons that can
shoot through walls and cars why does
any individual person need that you
don't need it to hunt for sport and you
don't need to be able to buy or sell
guns without a background check
you just don't and the right already
knows how to prevent changes to the laws
they will always say well listen
background checks alone wouldn't have
prevented this incident and banning
assault style weapons wouldn't have
prevented that incident because handguns
were used and mandatory mental health
reporting wouldn't have stopped this
other incident because the person didn't
have anything on their record mental
health related and then every measure or
all of the measures in total get framed
as these oppressive attempts to curtail
the Second Amendment and nothing gets
done right that's the process that's the
sequence that takes place and how is it
that a huge part of our population has
conceded that you just can't prevent it
that's the attitude of a lot of people
the desensitization combined with the
resignation gets people to say we just
can't stop it when we're the only modern
developed country in the world that has
this problem to this degree how is it
possible that we can't stop it plus we
know about the loopholes and the
problems with our vetting systems like
this individual in particular he was
expelled for fighting at school that
should have raised some red flags
probably should not have passed that
background check and should not have
been able to have access to those
weapons well that depends on how the
background check system is structured
how so-called mental health checks are
set up and I hate to break it to you but
as far as background checks go if we
couldn't pass universal background
checks with Obama in office after the
Sandy Hook shooting with 85 to 90
percent support from Americans for them
it is going to be damn near impossible
to get anything done because we have
this sick thing in this country
we're people's entire identities
personal identities political activism
identities it's all tied up in the idea
of owning guns and for some the reality
of owning guns as well millions and
millions of dollars are raised around
the idea that someone usually a Democrat
but if it's if it's a non-white Democrat
even better they are going to want to
take your guns and of course under
President Obama the opposite happened
more gun sales that it's so so so much
time and I'm not saying that nobody
wants change right because look at the
polling after Sandy Hook as I mentioned
overwhelming support for 100% background
checks close to 90% still couldn't get
it done and it's just not happen
in other countries in this way so are we
admitting that we can't fix it are we
admitting that we prefer this number of
shootings as long as we can keep our
guns in the way that the Second
Amendment fetishists want because if
that's what we're doing that SiC and if
you want to really think about how bad
it's gotten go back to the
desensitization yesterday after you
found out about this what did you do and
I'm not saying you did anything wrong
because I did the same thing I turned on
Olympic ski jumping and thought wow they
go 80 miles an hour down the hill that
is part of the problem it's it's hard to
hold on to hope especially given the
fact that after Sandy Hook when a
classroom of six and seven-year-olds
were gunned down the Congress and the
president weren't able to do anything
because there just wasn't enough support
there yeah if it wasn't able to happen
in that instance could it happen in this
one I doubt it I have the same
skepticism sadly and there's not even a
desire for it that's part of the problem
that yes overwhelmingly the background
checks had big support and it still
wasn't done because the elected
officials we have weren't going to do it
and we could point to lobbyist influence
money and politics whatever else but
when you get back from background checks
which is relatively uncontroversial at
the popular sort of at the national
level by voters how are you going to
restrict guns or make any of these other
big changes when even the things that
are sort of low hanging fruit aren't
happening
it's absolutely disgusting and we're
gonna be talking about more we'll talk
more about this later today in the voice
mail segment and then also on tomorrow's
program but in the meantime send me your
thoughts what what should happen what
could happen I'm on twitter at des
Pakman and the show is on twitter at
david pakman show the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership